are you not hearing back do you feel
like you're getting ghosted during the
job search this video is for you
welcome back to another episode of
Udacity career tips my name is marcin
McGovern and this week we're gonna be
talking about non responses or ghosting
during the job search so if you're
curious about what companies keep saying
they're gonna get back to you by Friday
but then never do we're gonna be digging
into a few reasons why that might be
happening and also why it might not be
you so why are you not hearing back
first off I want to assure you that
you're not alone in this feeling that no
one's responding to you throughout your
job search most people are not hearing
back from the applications that they're
sending out as a matter of fact the
typical response rate for applying to
the online portals like indeed and
LinkedIn and all those different
websites is like two to five percent max
eighty percent of jobs have found
through people you know so if you're
primarily using online portals you're
normal if no one's getting back to you
this is nothing to freak out about yet
and it's all part of the process albeit
an incredibly frustrating part of the
process but the key thing I want you to
remember from this video is that you're
not alone and you're probably not a
failure just because people are ghosting
you and not responding let's explore a
few reasons why you might not be hearing
back number one they just don't have the
time to get back to you most people you
meet throughout the job search aren't
doing this as their primary thing this
was a responsibility that was assigned
to them in addition to their day job
they're squeezing in all these
interviews and follow-ups and more in
between all of their meetings and
assignments and other work that they're
trying to get done so when they have to
choose between sending out a follow-up
to a candidate who may or may not have
gotten the job or sending that TPS
report to their boss who wanted it on
their desk yesterday there's a good
chance of their boss took priority and
they just didn't have the time to
respond to you try not to take that
personally another good reason is that
the hiring process is broken in most
companies as the job seeker we're all
waiting around for a thank you next it's
been almost a month we just want to know
yes or no why don't you just tell us it
can feel like an eternity
however most companies are just not set
up technologically to handle the amount
of applications they receive when they
post a brand-new job listing without an
autumn
Maenads system set up to send thank you
next emails out to everyone who applied
for the job the vast majority of people
are just not going to get a response
there's no way one person can sit behind
a computer and send 300 or 400 I'm sorry
this isn't the right role this isn't the
right time emails so unfortunately as we
live in this world of broken technology
we're gonna have a lot of ghosting and
Nan responses as the norm and number
three they just never saw your
application this one is far more common
than you think
with online profiles making it easier
and easier to apply for jobs you know
what I'm talking about that one click to
apply button sometimes it's just very
difficult to get through all the noise
there's a good chance that your
application got filtered by the portal
website the AES system the intern that
went through the first round of resumes
the HR person that went through the
second round of resumes the junior on
the team who went through the third
round the senior on the team that went
through the fourth round and so on and
so forth there's so many layers between
you and the decision-maker there's a
good chance the person who makes a
decision never even saw your application
and that's why networking is so
important because 80% of jobs are found
through people you know if you have an
internal referral if you know someone at
the company if you've spent the time to
build a network to get your foot in the
door you don't have to deal with all
these layers you can just jump cut the
line and get to the front so
unfortunately if we're not doing those
things there's a good chance we're not
gonna hear back from companies because
they just never saw this in the first
place and this is just three of possibly
hundreds of reasons that you're not
hearing back during the job search
process the key here is to not take it
personally to have empathy for the
hiring teams that are trying their best
and to seek out personal connections
that can get you in the back door and if
you do that you'll actually have a
personal connection that you can reach
out to when you haven't heard back in a
while and ask yo what's up where we at
in the process here if you do this
instead of getting sucked into the job
board black holes that exist on the
internet you'll find that you get a lot
more responses during your job search so
keep it up keep positive and instead of
worrying about whether or not they're
getting back to you put that energy into
the next application because there are
plenty more fish in the sea
that's it for today thank you so much
for watching Udacity career tips if you
know someone who's struggling with the
job search right now share this video
with them and let them know you're
thinking about them we look forward to
bringing you more information like this
in videos to come and wish you the best
of luck in your job search
thanks again